each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so um this today we have
the the opportunity to have um Emily
Hill come and visit us for a and then
give a talk so she did her PhD at
Delaware with Lori Pollock and for the
past year almost year and a half she's
been associate professor at Montclair
State um and she's here visiting us
today talk about uh her work on natural
language programming and uh in software
engineering MH so take it
away all
right so in general my research is
motivated by the problem where you've
got this huge source code base and
someone's got to maintain it and the
poort maintenance developer needs to
somehow identify the code that they're
looking
for and there's a couple steps that they
take in trying to locate that code if
they don't have an expert available to
tell them where to look then they have
to do something else so one way to
locate relevant methods and Fields is by
searching the source code and trying to
look for big regions of the code that
might be relevant and then further
exploring those areas to see to refine
their understanding and really see what
else is relevant to exactly what the
task they're trying to solve so today
what I'm going to talk about is how we
can use the natural language and the
source code the words and the comments
the identifiers to help the developer
search and explore and understand their
code more
effectively and in fact research has
shown that developers spend more time
finding and understanding code than
fixing bugs so we can help reduce the
high cost of software maintenance if we
can speed up this
process so what are the current
approaches that developers typically use
in addressing these issues well there's
a wide variety of navigation and
exploration tools and those are commonly
built into idees using the program
structure like the a the call graph the
type hierarchy and it allows the
developer to jump to related source code
these are techniques that developers use
all the time and they're great they take
advantage of the program structure but
sometimes they can be predominantly
manual and slow for very large and
Scattered code bases because each
navigation step has to be initiated and
if your code takes multiple steps every
time you're locating a new piece of code
you're initiating navigation step after
navigation step to navigate that program
structure so what's an alternative well
there are search tools which work
similar to how we search the internet
using either Google or Bing and they
apply string matching with these
comments and identifiers and so they do
allow you to locate large and Scattered
codes but they tend to have a problem
with returning many irrelevant results
and missing a lot of relevant ones
because if a developer enters in a query
and it doesn't match the words the
original developer used in the source
code then the search results not going
to return anything relevant so both
tools have strengths but both all both
also have
challenges so how can we go about
improving these software maintenance
tools to help facilitate software
maintenance so our observation is that
programmers Express Concepts when
writing code so they use the program
structure IFL statements method calls
what algorithmic steps the order they
organize their statements within their
code but also the natural language the
words and the comets and the identifiers
so our approach is to leverage both
these sources of information to try and
build more effective software
engineering tools and our specific
Target is software
maintenance so let me give you an
example of combining program structure
and natural language information
together so let's say we have an auction
sniping program it allow us to
automatically bid on an eBay auction
online and we're looking for the code
that implements adding an auction so the
user is going to add an auction to the
system and I happen to know from prior
prior experience with the system that do
action is the method that handles all
user triggered events if I'm just using
program structure I can see that do
action calls 40 methods that's not
terrible but only two of those 40 are
relevant so going through that list of
40 is a for use of the developer's time
if I use natural language alone and
search the entire code base I get about
50 methods 90 matches across 50 methods
and I located the relevant two but I
also located tons of irrelevant ones but
if we combine this information and put
it together we can locate the two
relevant ones with just one false
positive so narrowing our list of 40 to
50 methods to just three for the
developer to look through so we want to
try and combine program language program
structure and natural language to help
us improve tools and get better
information okay please feel free to
interrup clarification um with that when
was that an intersection of the
programming language answers and the the
natural language answers to get to well
we use basically we use search
techniques the natural language on the
program structure so the subset we only
searched the 40 Coles of du action no
good question when you say sort of
natural language alone are you talking
about sematic analysis at all are you
just saying just the comment section uh
Mo so comments and identifiers so any
word any text that shows up but any sort
of syntactical analysis are you doing
that also um when you say natural
language so usually I mean bag of words
at the base level although we've been
working to build more semantic and
syntactic Analysis on top of that okay
so I'll actually show you what I mean by
that down the road but strictly natural
language information what it boils down
to is somehow using the words whether
that's just straight list of these this
set of words is in a method or if it's
more advanced than
that so and actually thank you that
leads me right to my next point is that
when using this natural language
information and combining it with
program structure it's not enough to use
the words alone independently the
context of how the words appears is very
important so for example we have three
occurrences of the word map so we have
map object in a method name where map is
playing the role of a verb or an action
versus object map which is like a hash
map that contains object so that's
really its noun sense and then we might
have the words map and object just on
two completely unrelated statements in
the method but the word map shows up so
the context of how that word's appearing
if it's a query word is very important
to improving our accuracy for the search
as well as the location of the word for
example a method signature is typically
a better summary or abstraction of what
a method's doing than a random word just
anywhere in the method body and so we
try and leverage that information to
help improve accuracy as
well so let me show you an example of
why using context and location is so
important so for example I like adding
things to my so if we're searching for
add item in a piece of shopping cart
software for example on the left I have
a method add entry and on the right I
have a method called sum so both are
different senses of the word add so when
I talk about context I'm talking about
going from lexical Concepts which is the
individual words itself commonly
referred to as a bag of words approach
and information retrieval versus phrasal
Concepts so if we look at just straight
word occurrences both of these methods
contain the words add and item both
equally match but if we evolve that to
phrasal Concepts so Concepts that
consist of multiple words we can see
that the left hand side at entry
actually is adding an item whereas some
is actually adding a price so by taking
advantage of these phrasal Concepts we
can better identify the relevant add
entry method over the irrelevant sum in
addition location further helps us so
the phrasal Concept in the signature for
add entry is add item entry which again
contains the query words of add item
whereas the signature in sum is simply
sum and we could put in a direct object
there if we wanted but helping the
looking the location the method
signature versus the body further helps
us figure out what the topic of this
method what action is really trying to
take so I'm going to talk a little bit
about our work for query query
reformulation which is where we help the
developer select query words and
determine result relevance which was the
motivation for our next step which was
developing a model of word usage in
software to actually capture these
phrasal Concepts in a general way that's
usable by software engineering tools
besides just software search and then
how does that model with phrasal
Concepts help us improve software search
how can we take advantage of natural
language and program structure and
program exploration and then if we
combine these two pieces together how
much can we Le lead to
improvements so any questions before I
change
topics okay well not really changing
topics just changing problem slightly
okay so with query reformulation we're
concerned with helping the developer
pick the right query words to help
maximize the results of their search and
determine if the results are relevant or
not so when developers search source
code they typically start off with a
query that's executed by some search
method on the source code base and then
those results are return to the
developer I'm sure you've all
experienced this before whether it's on
the web or on a source code base
and if those results are relevant the
developer can stop their search if
they're not what they're looking for
they can continue to repeat this process
until they either get relevant results
or they get so frustrated they stop and
they walk away and they use some other
means to locate the code that they're
looking
for in this process the developer faces
two key challenges first in deciding
what query words they actually have to
search for and secondly in determining
whether or not those results are
relevant and I'm going to go into detail
as to why
those are so
challenging so first why is selecting a
query difficult well when we're
searching software we have to guess what
words the original developer used to
implement the concept and actually
research has shown that two people when
trying to select words to describe a
familiar concept only agree about 10 to
15% of the time so this is a really
really common problem not just in code
search but in searching in
general sorry mhm agreement without
talking to each other or agreement after
without talking to each other so two
people trying to describe like maybe
they saw a picture trying to pick words
to describe it are those developers or
just general
people I think the target was Developers
for this case although I would have to
double check that I don't hold me to
that I it may be it may be more general
information retrieval research result
there cuz I don't think that study has
been done for developers although uh
bigger staff is done some work on how
difficult it is to describe those
Concepts so the three major challenges
in selecting query words first you can
have multiple words with the same
meaning so you might formulate the query
delete but that concept is implemented
as remove RM or de as an
abbreviation then you might have a
single word that has multiple meanings
so add as we saw in our prior example
can mean either appending or adding to a
list versus summing and those are two
different senses you're going to get
irrelevant results if you use that one
General word and even if you pick the
exactly right word to describe the
concept you're looking for let's say
going back to our auction sniping
program example let's say you want the
code that implements the data storing
the auctions in the system auction is
clearly the right word but it's an
auction sniping program the word auction
is going to appear everywhere throughout
the code so it's not a good
discriminator so even if the word is
perfectly correct and accurate if it's
too frequently occurring it's not going
to be specific enough to get you the
results you're looking for so all three
of these challenges really conspire to
make it difficult to come up with a good
query then it really makes it difficult
for the Search tool to try and suit any
arbitrary query anyone could think up
all the time so it actually becomes very
challenging so that's the first
challenge we're trying to address the
Second Challenge is why is determing
result relevance so difficult well
typically in a typical IDE when we we do
a keyword search or regular expression
search typically the results are
presented just in a list with the
relevant results we have to read through
the code to find if the results are
relevant or not so the
challenge if we think about when we
search the web it's very easy to pull
out where our query words appear what
their context is they're bold the query
words are bold-faced in the context of
the sentences where they're used the
titles of the web pages are nice and a
big bold font they're bigger they're a
different color and so it's much easier
when I enter a query into something like
bang or Google I can quickly see ah did
my was my query even right before I even
go looking to answering whatever
question I have the reason I made the
search I can quickly figure out if my
query is even in the ballpark but with
source code the developer could actually
waste time trying to understand code
that's not even relevant and to me
that's like the the biggest crime is
that understanding code is hard enough
without having to understand code just
to figure fig out if your query was
getting you the right source code mhm so
could you do something similar to what
Google does I mean they highlight the
relevant words and they show it in some
context right is there a reason why you
couldn't do that or is that where you're
going that is kind of where I'm going
and actually you could take that idea
further I have only pushed it a little
bit in terms of we're going to use
phrases to embed those query words and
give that context because it's easier to
read a natural language phrase than some
source code but you could even go
further and highlight even more are
there studies to show how long takes to
scan through a list of search results
like the old staff yeah I don't I don't
think so and I think it's highly
dependent on how expert you are and how
familiar you are with the code system so
we normally assume that the person
searching has very little familiarity
with the code system and so they're
going to take the longest if you know
the code base you're probably going to
be really get pretty good at filtering
out the irrelevant results but a
newcomer to a system that's really
unfamiliar they're probably going to
have to read each result and it depends
on how fast you read how quickly you are
but no I don't I'm not aware of any
studies that have evaluated that I've
heard galey mentioned even that I don't
know if it's for papers that it it can
take like multiple minutes per and that
people will typically like give up after
5 to 10 like she seen developers going
down the list like not even go down
that's like Google yeah give up after
the first three yep or one five to 10 or
one yeah I mean they don't scroll no the
average I think for information
retrieval in general the average is 5 to
10 they'll look at five to 10 results
and if they don't see it they'll give up
but the in that that code list it's just
alphabetically in in most cases and so
if you're alphabetical listing of file
names it doesn't show up right away you
might have the right query and just not
know it so if we could really get the
developer to figure out is their query
even right and then hone in on the
correct results that that's our goal so
the problem is that search results in
general can't be quickly skimmed which
we're going to try and change and the
results are poorly organized so you have
to decide the relevance of each result
you you have 50 matches you might look
at the first five to 10 if you were
really really exhaustive you might look
at all of them but you have to keep
determining the relevance and making
that decision for each search result so
we'd like to change
that so our key Insight is that the
context of the query words in the source
code is going to enable skimming
organization of results and provide
faster feedback for poor queries we
don't claim that we can automatically
correct the developer query only they
understand their information need but if
we can give them that feedback faster so
they can more quickly change their query
that's a win for us so we're going to
automatically capture our context by
generating phrases from the source code
so for example if I had the signature
add item I could generate a phrase add
new book item for example or update
event compare playlist file to object or
load history so for example if our query
is load we can quickly see that this
result is loading history versus loading
a file
downloading a file delivering a payload
so just by seeing how the query word
appears with other words in the
signature will help us make that
determination more quickly and we try
and make it faster to read because
usually humans can read natural language
sentences faster than source
code
okay and we're going to organize these
phrases into a hierarchy and I'll show
you an example of how we do
that okay so if we take an example task
let let's say we're searching a
JavaScript interpreter for ass signed
integer conversion so our query is 2 int
and there are 30 results for 2 in which
I've listed to the right and we could
look through this entire list or if we
could use our phrases to try and group
them together we might be able to hone
in on the relevant results
faster so the phrase hierarchy at the
very top is the query 2 in 30 and below
that we have three sub phrases add value
to code in 16 object to int map and two
in 32 and since signed inner conversion
involves the 32 bit 2 in 32 is the sub
phrase that we're really interested in
that's where we think we'll find our
relevant
results so we're able to discard about
30 uh 27 of the other results and the
context of the query words in the phrase
helps us determine the relevance more
quickly so we're reducing the number of
relevance decisions from 30 results down
to just three phrases and then three
results to verify that those three
phrases those three results are the
correct relevant
signatures yes so we automatically
generate those phrases from the
signatures and they use a a partial
opportunistic phrase matching that
greedily groups them together into a
hierarchy yep mhm are those phrases
every identifier from the signature of
the method that you're considering or is
it just a subset so it's we usually
generate them for the entire signature
and I think in this iteration we also
generated it for the parameters too but
we tried to match the longest sub phrase
so that usually prevented us from
grouping based on like formal parameter
names unless that provided the largest
grouping does that make
sense
partially just keep going okay now we do
generate it for the parameters but
usually they're grouped in based on
their signatures and so typically their
base so for example to int notice we can
split up two an INT they don't have to
be right next to each other like add
value to code int
16 things like that so are these phrases
represented internally as just words or
do you have some sort of model sematic
model thank you that's actually exactly
where we're going so we started off with
strict phrases and then we recognized
the potential if we could build that
General model any software engineering
tool could use it and so that's our
ultimate goal so that's actually the
next section so almost
there all right and just to give you a
sense of how we generated the phrases
because this was kind of our starting
point for building the model um is that
fields and Constructors we naively
assumed they were all noun phrases they
didn't involve actions so file writer
report display panel and then we assume
that method names were verb phrases they
started with a verb and they had an
optional object after them so verb
phrases consist of a verb followed by a
direct object and an optional
preposition and indirect object and if
you've forgotten your grammar before I
did this research I didn't remember the
difference um if we take an example
phrase like add item to list add is the
verb and then two is a
preposition and then item is the direct
object and list is the indirect object
so we always look for a verb and a
direct object and if there is a
preposition in the method name then we
go hunting for the indirect object so
our real challenge was identifying the
direct and indirect objects of the verb
and we typically look first in the name
that's obviously the best indicator and
if it wasn't there we looked at the
first formal parameter and then at the
class name so for example get connection
type run I report compiler update event
or compare playlist file to object did
you find any uh sort of computer science
or programmer specific idioms that you
needed to also haveo mind like I mean I
see a lot of code that says x digigit 2
m y you know for Transformations from
next y yeah so we mostly
avoided two although I did have a
version of an identifier splitter that
pre-processed two and tried to use it
and make it convert so we did some work
with idioms like convert especially if
it starts with the preposition two two
string that's converting something to a
string digit right no I
know I I if I handled it it was during
the identifier splitting phase where I
could try to detect that um but in
general if it started with like a to
preposition we might infer convert um
and there were a couple special cases
but again it's all how much time do you
want to spend in doing that and so for
query reformulation just generating
these phrases we didn't actually need
that level of detail it still worked
pretty well but as we go to the more
General model we have to spend more and
more time in making that more accurate
and doing that parsing and I'll show you
how we go about doing that in
general so to evaluate
I called our query re formulation
technique contextual search because it
uses the context of query words and to
evaluate it we compared it with an
existing technique called verb direct
object which is very similar to our
technique except it's only the the verb
and the direct object it doesn't
consider any general noun phrase method
names or prepositional phrases and we
compared search results from 22
developers on 28 maintenance tasks they
were searching for 28 concerns or search
tasks
and here we have box plots for the
comparison between contextual search
which I've called context and verb Doo
on the right and they're box plot so the
middle shaded box represents the middle
50% of the data the horizontal line is
the median and plus is the mean and X's
represent outliers so we measured we
compared these two techniques in terms
of effort which we measured using the
number of queries the user entered
ideally we would have liked to measure
effort in terms of time but we didn't
want to tell our subjects that they were
being timed and some of them ate during
one half of the experiment but not in
the other and so unfortunately all we
have is the number of queries for effort
and also in terms of Effectiveness using
the common information retrieval measure
of fmeasure which combines precision and
recall and we could see that contextual
search requires less effort than verb
Doo and returned more effective results
which further justifies because
contextual search significantly
outperforms verb Doo it justifies going
down this path that the more accurate we
make our information instead of just
stopping with verbs and direct objects
and really trying to model noun phrases
and prepositional phrases we can
actually get significant improvements is
that a hand did the measurements or did
the comparisons hold true within
subjects for every subject yes yes
because that's how we ran it we did a
paired we ran it both ways we did the
two sample T Test as well as a paired
because it was a kind of a mixed model
result but yes it held for both of
them
yep okay although a lot of the subjects
liked what verb Doo did that contextual
search didn't was that it also did
co-occurring pairs so if you enter a
your query had to be a verb followed by
a direct object but if you entered a
verb it would list all the other
co-occurring direct objects and if you
entered a direct object it would list
all other co-occurring verbs and the
subjects did like seeing what other
words Co occurred with their query words
so they did really like that but it was
so limited because it only matched using
verb and direct object it couldn't there
were some search tasks that they
couldn't formulate queries for and
that's partly what led to it so a
combination ultimately would be ideal
and we're we're actually still working
on trying to take that to the next
level okay so any other questions about
that before I move on
okay so as you mentioned before we
started getting inspired by these
phrases and thinking gosh what else
could we do with them and another
student at the time actually wanted to
work on automatically generating
comments and we thought you know if we
could really turn these phrases into a
generalized model of the semantics of
the program structure and the natural
language and the underlying source code
it can be used in almost any S software
engineering tool that uses textual
information and so the challenge was
well how do we go from phrases to a
generalized model that more people can
be take advantage
of so with qu query reformulation our
phrases capture noun phrase and verb
phrase phrasal concepts for methods and
Fields so for example convert result
load history synchronized list but we
needed to generalize that model from a
textual
representation just with phrases to a
model of this phrasal structure so these
could be annotated with their different
roles in the natural language
and we also needed to improve the
accuracy for example if I'm going from a
method or field signature to a phrase I
could actually mistakenly label a verb
as a noun and the phrase would still
come out readable and correct but when
we want to internally represent it as a
phrasal concept we have to have a lot
higher accuracy so our goal is to
represent the conceptual knowledge of
the programmer as expressed in both the
program structure and the natural
language through these phrasal Concepts
so any piece we're trying to provide a
generalized model that can be used in
automated tools that represents or
encodes what a human sees when they read
code we're we're that's our goal where
we're trying to get
to so this is an overview of our
software word usage model which I'll
call swam and it consists of three
layers the top layer is the program
model which any program analysis any
program structure you've used before
that would fall into that layer ests
call graphs type hierarchies that's the
traditional analysis layer at the bottom
there's a word layer so each word
individually and that's what's typically
been used by textual analysis techniques
in the past that so-called bag of word
model so our real insight our
contribution is this interior middle
layer swam core Which models the phrasal
Concepts and that's where we do the
parsing of the words into verb phrases
and noun phrases and start annotating
them with action and theme now at this
level I'm switching to the words action
and theme from verb and direct object
because verb Doo are syntactic layer
information whereas action and theme are
more semantic slightly higher level
Concepts so that's but for all intents
and purposes you can think of them as
verb and direct objects you won't be far
off okay and so we have three different
types of nodes one for each layer
program element nodes word nodes and
then phrase structure noes which
represent the phrasal
Concepts and in terms of edges within
each layer we have edges the top we have
structural edges in the middle we have
parse edges at the bottom we have word
edges so we can represent things for
example you could do synonyms or stems
if you want to know that adding is the
same as ADD you could put that kind of
word relationship in the bottom layer
and between the layers we have the
bridge edges that allow us to go from
the program structure to the phrase
structure so you can navigate and take
advantage of all the information the As
and call graph as well as all the semant
information between the parses and the
phrasal Concepts so we're really trying
to provide an integrated solution so
that people don't tool developers don't
have to understand all the parsing
details but they can still leverage
textual information in their software
engineering tools and so our goal is
that if we had a model like this we
could provide an interface between
people that want to use textual
information and people that are working
on improving the accuracy of the parsing
layer just similar to how the PDG became
an interface for researchers and
developers using Pro analyses so that's
our ultimate goal might not be swam
could be something similar but that's
what we're working
towards so what are some of the
challenges in automatically constructing
such a model well first we have to
accurately identify the part of speech
this is a well understood problem for
natural language but in the subdomain of
software it becomes even more
challenging so for example the same word
might have multiple parts of speech and
actually I really like the example fire
because in natural language it's
typically a noun you see fire and you
try to put it out but in source code
fire is often a verb it can be a noun
modifier like an adjective or it can be
the noun if it was in a gaming system
and so for every word in an identifier
we have to somehow Identify some kind of
part of speech for it if we want to
accurately parse the identifier names
and so our approach is to use both the
position of the word in the identifier
and its location is it in a field is it
in a method is it in a Constructor to
help us try and disambiguate what part
of speech the word
is and then after we've identified the
parts of speech then we need to parse
them by identifying the action theme and
secondary Arguments for any method verb
phrases we have noun phrases are very
simple we don't go beyond noun modifiers
and nouns so we don't differentiate
between adjectives or nouns that have
become adjectives things like that but
verb phrases and identifying these
themes and secondary arguments that's
where the challenge
is so for
example we have a reactive method action
performed which doesn't tell us much
about what the method's doing so that we
don't have a very good solution for yet
handle action performed tear down set
group test convert restriction to
minimum cardinality or add auction entry
and what we've done in phrase generation
we just generated all the phrases so we
would generate add entry add auction
entry we just generate them all but in
the building this model we try to take a
step back so we can present as much and
preserve as much information as possible
for the end tool because we don't know
exactly what that tool is going to be so
now what we do is we would say the
action is ADD and there's two themes
entry and auction entry and those are
equivalent they describe the same thing
so we would figure out where if there is
a direct object in the name does it
overlap a parameter do the do the
headwords the last words to the right of
the phrase do they overlap and so we
would identify that those are
equivalent M sorry do you want me to go
back no go ahead no
okay ask at the end okay so how do we go
about developing these swam construction
rules so our research process is to
analyze how developers actually use
words in code and so the concept behind
any machine learning or natural language
technique is that if a human can
recognize it we can train some automatic
tool to recognize it but you have to be
careful of cost benefit analysis sure I
can recognize anything in human can but
how long is it going to take me to
develop those rules so we're we've been
highly motivated by our Target software
engineering applications career
formulation required the least analysis
it still worked really well we generated
really reasonable phrases with very with
with not as accurate rules and then for
search I didn't need to be quite as
accurate as we needed to be for Comet
generation when we're actually
generating text for human consumption
that summarizes a method we had to be
even more accurate and so we've been
refining our rule identification process
to be more and more accurate each
iteration with each new tool we're
targeting so for example I started with
9,000 open source Java programs because
they're available it's what I had on
hand and we'll start with those
identifier names and try to classify
each name into a partition the first
easiest way is to classify them into
method names and field names and then
I'll analyze each partition and evaluate
the accuracy of our current approach on
a random subset so for example we could
start and assume that every method name
starts with a verb and in fact that's
where we started with phrase generation
for querier formulation is we assumed
every method name did start with a verb
and we look at our random subset and we
can see that's true for the first three
methods but for size and length those
are actually Getters with noun phrases
noun beginnings two string and next
start with prepositions and synchronized
list actually starts with an adjective
so our next challenge is to refine our
approach and our
classification first we identify which
partitions are missing that's usually
the easy part but then we have to figure
out how to automatically identify and
categorize these method signatures into
those
partitions and we would continue
repeating this process on a random
sample until we were happy with the
level of accuracy for our Target
software engineering application so as
we keep evolving this representation
over time we're working to impr to
improve the accuracy more and
more so we have this model but how
expensive is it is it going to scale to
really really big software well in terms
of space if you build the entire model
it contains node for every identifier
and every unique word that's used and
the number of edges is linear with
respect to the number of words within
those identifiers and what whatever
structure or word information is
included in the model so that may be
very dependent on your target software
engineering application based on how
much program structure information you
need do you just need the a or do you
need more than that in terms of time it
can be constructed incrementally built
incrementally and constructed on demand
so that helps limit the costs I created
an unoptimized research prototype and to
give you a sense for how long that took
I analyzed signatures for a 74,000 line
of code program in 11 seconds and 1.5
million lines of code in 11 minutes so
we consider that to be reasonable for
most of the codes we're looking at but I
don't think they're quite as large as
what you guys might be looking at so
that would definitely be something to
consider um and there are some
optimizations that can be done first you
can optimize by the level of program
structure and accuracy that you need for
example in career formulation I didn't
need the level of accuracy I needed for
searching so some optimizations can be
improve that way and it could also be
constructed once and used in many
software engineering tools so if you
wanted to commit to this kind of
representation for a wide variety of
software engineering tools it would make
more sense to use the expensive analysis
because you'd get to reuse it over and
over again across different software
engineering tools and because it can be
built incrementally it can be updated
incrementally overnight so you just have
the one cost up front the first big time
batch and then you could incrementally
update it as the code evolves
so what other software engineering tools
can it be used
in so so far we've applied it to source
code search also known as concern
location as well as program
comprehension and development we've
applied it to automatically generating
comments to summarize what a method's
doing it could also be used for
automatic documentation program changes
automatic recommendation of API methods
a novice programming tutor anywhere you
could use text to help solve a software
engineering problem you can take
advantage of this kind of analysis in
terms of traceability linking software
artifacts together external
documentation emails bug reports to the
source code um that involves getting a
representation that's similar to swam
for those natural language artifacts in
theory that's the easier problem because
analysis tools exist for natural
language text in general although they
have to be probably tweaked for certain
types of software artifacts we could
also work on building more intuitive
natural language based interfaces for
example from debugging the Y Line
interface by Cohen Myers they were
asking questions about the program
execution they were pre-canned
pre-programmed in we might be able to
allow the user to ask more informative
questions they could initiate rather
than just having a list of questions
possibly and also helps with text mining
of software repositories for example we
can use this kind of representation to
automatically build a word net for
software synonyms by looking at verbs
that are in the method signature as well
as in the body uh and also to continue
improving our swm's construction rules
so we can use swam to help improve swam
in the future and make it more accurate
but anywhere you could use text to solve
a software engineering problem that's
really where this could be used as long
as it's worth it as long as this is
adding something adding value adding
accuracy so any questions about the
general model before I show its
Improvement in something like
search yes okay um when you were trying
to distinguish between the ad entry and
whether it's an auction entry or distant
entry could you have you considered also
looking at the call sites to see what
the variable is that they call the
variable name of the thing that got
passed in as the argument to that method
that's another name for what yes so I
was just demonstrating the signature
level analysis but yes when we actually
analyze method call we take into account
both the formal the actual its type of
the variable we so we have like four
sources of information the variable's
name and type for both the actual and
the formal and we may have an additional
source of information if the method call
as a whole is nested inside another
method that's like a su the formal
parameter for whatever that's a
parameter for is also a summary related
so yeah we do chain them together when
we get to the within the method body
analysis we do chain those all together
to extract as much every last drop of
information we
can MH oh sorry oh so I I guess two
questions one it seems like this is
specific to the natural language being
used um I suspect that a large majority
of codes person uses like English
identifiers and things but um my two
questions are how difficult would it be
like if you were working on a German Cod
base or Chinese or whatever and do you
have any notion of how prevalent that is
I mean have you seen open source code
that's written in a different Lang
yeah my 9,000 programs contain German
and French and Spanish and Italian but
it's not a lot but it's there it's
clearly
there change your techniques languages
do the structure maybe different Well
yeah if if they're structuring the
identifiers differently so the challenge
is if they're used to writing in English
and they just start writing in another
language they might actually still
follow English naming convention
patterns just with different words
that's really simple to address but if
they're actually changing the structure
of how they name things like German can
have a different phrase structure I
think than English does and if they
don't start their method names with
verbs anymore then you have to
completely develop a new part of speech
analysis for that so it is challenging
when it's if it's not just a
substitution if things are kind of in
the same positions they follow similar
naming conventions it's just different
words that's just a new dictionary that
that's easy but if they actually reorder
it do you just use like an off the-shelf
classifi determ like what's a noun what
is a verb right and so you'd have and
there are a lot of them that exist for
other like natural languages and so it's
just a matter of tailoring them the some
of the same techniques we've used used
to specialize them for software would
work there but you need some sense of
the naming conventions used I think
really the big limitation of this is
it's based on naming conventions and if
you change those significantly whether
it's another language natural language
or another programming language you're
going to have to do a lot more work if
you're going from this is mostly done in
Java if you're going to other
object-oriented languages like we've
looked at C++ there are many
similarities but you have to just re
verify them make sure that they're still
following the same naming conventions
and that would apply whether you're
looking at a natural or a programming
language change
do you find me some uh this information
is just not very useful like the names
are poorly
chosen so for scientific software all
bets are off like predominantly par
highly parallel codes scientific codes
where the variable names are all XYZ ABC
this is not going to work well we know
that we that's kind of a subdomain that
we're analyzing separately because it
has separate challenges so we
predominately looked at open source
codes are typically gooey applications
they're they have user interfaces they
have features that are typically welln
named because they're open source and
they have to use the source code as a
communication mechanism between the
developers um other places where it
doesn't work well are are what we call
reactive method names like API method
names if you're overriding an interface
you didn't get any choice in selecting
that method name so we have to really
rely on the method bodies to build the
semantic model or generate the summaries
for common generation for example so
that's but you can as long as inside
that API method as long as you've
implemented some meaningful words then
we can still use it but you're saying
you also do look at the program
structure within a function the the
actual statements yeah depending on
which problem we're solving for search I
haven't gone that level because it's too
expensive but for comment generation we
we have to because we're trying to
generate a sum a summary of a method
automatically so but yes we do have
method mechanisms for analyzing and
trying to summarize the substatement so
we have some analysis for Loops for if
statements for blocks of statements to
summarize what they're doing in general
summarizing that action and so the same
Concepts can be used to automatically
debug method names by looking at what
the inside is does it match what the
method name itself is like a Setter that
doesn't set
anything you know that's an example of
things we can detect using this
mechanism
M any other questions before I move on
okay
I ran out of water
okay okay so now my target application
that I've been mostly interested in
using this model is to improve search
can we make search more accurate for
software and really I'm mostly concerned
with improving the Precision and so
that's where the phrasal Concepts come
in so this is a a specific example of
swam to give you a better understanding
of how we're using it so that top left I
have a very small snippet of code so
it's main object. Java the method is
called handle fatal error and it has one
line of code CIS logger DOD print and
it's printing an error the program
structure representation of that method
call in the body is CIS logger is in so
dprint the method dprint is invoked on
the expression CIS logger and it has an
actual parameter of error and that maps
to the phrase structure all the way to
the right I've gone ahead and put the
word nodes right in the phrase structure
layer that's usually how I think about
it but technically these can be three
separate layers and it helps with the
optimization but for readability I've
put them all up here so the gray nodes
are the phrase structure nodes so we
have the verb phrases prepositional
phrase and a noun phrase and the white
nodes or the word
nodes so for search what we use are
these different semantic roles we have
an action do print we have a theme or a
direct object error our secondary
argument is two sis loger in this case
we've inferred the preposition two and
we have some rules to do that but it's
not General it's just there's some
specific ones we can look for and we
also have an auxiliary argument um if we
have additional formal parameters so for
example error is our theme we might find
that that's equivalent to the error in
the formal parameter for example so we
have addition we can have additional
auxiliary arguments especially if there
is a whole list of additional formal
parameters any of them
that's not
Boolean is usually added to the
auxiliary argument list unless it starts
with a verb that we know typically has
bullan arguments but I'm I'm getting
into low-level details there so but the
really important thing is that we have
these different semantic roles action
theme secondary argument if there's some
kind of preposition involved and any
remaining auxiliary arguments so that we
can throw all the information from the
signature all the information we can
find into one of these semantic roles
and we take that into account in
calculating our relevant
score we also take into account the head
distance which is the location within
the phrase structure so in natural
language phrases there's this concept
that the word all the way to the right
in the phrase the last word in a phrase
is it is the headword and it's really
the theme of that phrase so for example
we have the phrase CIS logger it's less
about CIS or system and more about
logger because logger is in the position
of the head so logger is would be
labeled as head and CIS would be labeled
as one away from the head and so we also
use that head distance because if a
query word appears in the head position
it that method or that phrase is more
likely to be relevant to the query in
that
case so the different sources of
information we use as I just mentioned
we use the semantic role and we assume
that Cory word occurrences in the action
and the theme are more relevant than
occurrences and other argument roles
that's inspired by the verb direct
object approach that was used before and
we also take into account the head
distance which that's a new aspect that
hasn't been involved in software search
before as that The Closer the query word
is to this head position the more
strongly the phrase relates to the query
word so for example in our auction
example special auction has more to do
with auction than auction server because
auction server is really about a server
which happens to hold auctions whereas a
special auction is actually an
auction and the idea is to be greedy and
so that we have a diminishing head
distance so that as long as the word
appears somewhere in the phrase it comes
up as relevant but we want we've chosen
the score so that if it always appears
in the head position that'll obviously
hit first and later down on the list
we'll have other occurrences of the
query words just in case to be greedy if
the query word never appeared in the
head position for example so we try to
do a best effort and additional
information we use is the location query
words appearing in the signature we
believe more strongly indicate relevance
than appearances in the body and as with
traditional information retrieval
techniques they typically use inverse
document frequency to approximate usage
in the rest of the program so that
frequently occurring words throughout
the entire program typically aren't good
discriminators and so we we inversely
wait their contribution to the score
using IDF was that
okay in that one you might do SE
the difference between the method
signature and the body because if you
have printf it's going to frequently
occur in lots of bodies but as a method
signature there's only one so actually
we we segment it just based on
identifier splitting and whether not
we're using stemming so we just split
all the words and we use that as the IDF
we don't we haven't done a location
based IDF although that would be an
interesting thing to try and see but the
problem is is that we don't know what
the user is searching for do they want
just the signatures or not and so that's
the challenge is figuring out how does
the user specify do they know that
they're looking at a certain role and if
they had that information certainly we
could take advantage of it but I think
that's the challenge of why we haven't
done it
yet any more okay uh so this is a this
is great but it's very different from
like a browser you know search uh if
users are sort of Interest or used to
doing it one way how can you sort of
wake them up and say hey here's we do
things slightly different but it's
better and have you thought about well
our idea is that we want to make the
query mechanism as simple as possible
it's it we want the query mechanism to
be a short two to three-word phrase the
same way you'd search on the internet
that's our goal and that's why we're
going through all jumping through all
these hoops to try and make a short
query be effective because really the
search problems are very different when
you're searching the web you have an
information need you probably have a
question and as soon as you get one web
page that's relevant that answers your
question you're done but when I'm
searching code for maintenance purposes
I need every relevant occurrence I'm not
satisfied with just one relevant result
I need all of the relevant results and
so that's why we're working so hard to
really try and get precise and then we
bring in program exploration techniques
to try and improve the recall because
right now we're searching over so many
different methods how can we find the
ones that are the most relevant to the
query and then can we refine those
further to improve the recall that's
kind of our approach mhm so it seems
like you're operating the the constraint
that a query is like a sequence of words
um and by providing some summary you're
allowing them to to kind of in their
head think oh I'm looking for a
signature or I'm looking for for
something but but couldn't you rather
than displaying everything so they could
filter allow them to filter uh
preemptively by just saying when you
query instead of just providing just
words also here are some things I care
about like I only care about methods or
I only care about you know a class or or
providing some additional information in
the query instead of trying to provide
it in the summary later on for them to
sense definitely no you could definitely
the more information they can give us we
just don't want to enforce that we want
to allow the ability like the holy grail
for me has been I should be able to
search for my source code as easily as I
search the web with with Google or Bing
for example and so try but as we refine
this and try and better meet developer
needs I think we're going to find we're
going to have to add things like that
into that but so far we're just trying
to make a general solution how far can
we push it how accurate can we get but
it is really hard to make a general
solution that works well because there's
so many different types of information
needs and so many different reasons the
developer might be searching it is hard
to be all things to everyone so I think
our next steps are further specializing
y I mean like if you think of web search
what you frequently have this like page
optimization so it's easier to find mhm
like if you have like if you would
change how people right um identifiers
method names how would you change like
what would be yeah what would make it
easier for your approach to code to be
found oh right so you could based on the
rules we've learned we can provide
guidelines to developers that if you
write your code and and follow these
patterns we're going to be better able
to find it definitely so what we've
tried to do is use naming conventions
and patterns that developers use over a
wide variety of source code but if
especially if there are uh company
mandated naming conventions and you
follow those we can increase the rules
and the accuracy a lot so definitely if
that can be if developers can have that
information it would definitely help us
improve our accuracy
certainly yep although we're we've made
our problem Harder by assuming that we
don't have that luxury and trying to
still be successful how much how far can
we push it how accurate can we get I
really think the accuracy is still only
around like 70 70% % F measure because
there is a limitation to using the words
alone because sometimes there's going to
be methods that just don't contain any
relevant words and that's the challenge
we can't so there there's like a bar and
we're just trying to see can we reach
that bar and then how do we keep going
Beyond it speaking of methods with
relevant words um what do you do for
abbreviations um well I have an a
technique for abbreviation expansion but
it's not quite accurate enough yet that
I've thrown it in here and so that's
partly why we've pushed the qu
reformulation technique so the developer
can more quickly explore how it's
actually implemented so if they wanted
to use both the abbreviation and its
full form they could add that in but by
seeing what the words are used for but
yeah right now we're not taking that
into account there's certainly more room
for synonyms abbreviations all of those
things right now we're just strictly
going off the words
themselves is there any way that you
could leverage
um developers to help you in this test
so like if you know okay my blind spots
here are methods that I just can't
reason about m is is could you say okay
you get an hours of a developers time to
annotate right like like I don't know
these abbreviations I can't expand them
or something like that have you thought
about like cuz people aren't going to
annotate everything right but sometimes
if you can can use people's time really
effectively and they get some payoff
later no definitely we haven't really
thought about that but that is a really
good idea if we could get developers to
do that a lot of this unfortunately we
do ourselves and so we're relying on our
analysis warning like this isn't very
well named yeah exact if you know your
BLS are right I've seen work that
actually says this is named badly right
fix this exactly and yeah if we could
integrate that into ID and collect that
information then we could really help
improve our our tools definitely any any
information is
helpful so one additional source of
information that's been crucial for web
search is the notion of a static rank of
a page like what's the prior relevance
of this this piece of information and it
feels like you could incorporate that
same sort of information here right like
maybe um if if a piece of code has a lot
of callers or colle like it's sort of a
hub or authority in the colleag graph it
might have greater relevance if if it
spents more of program execution time
inside that piece of code maybe it's
more important maybe it's closer to the
main function it's more important like
it feels like there's a bunch of sort of
Prior signals about the relevance of a
piece of code which could not only be
used to help relevance but also identify
where you get the most bang for the buck
if you're going to ask your developers
to spend more time on things exact put
any time in like this prior uh so we
haven't used any relevance feedback yet
although there are some techniques that
have that have used the Hub and
Authority um type of mechanism um
although it was counterintuitive and
they had to actually turn it around it
was like the hubs were not the places
you wanted to go you because they were
so interconnected it means they're so
General they're not useful but um they
have taken that into account so we've
focused purely on how much can we get
from the structure and the words but
actually adding in some kind of Hub and
Authority would be really helpful
I think if we could use it to accurately
identify it because obviously we Getters
and Setters low-l methods we don't want
those you probably don't want ones that
too high either you kind of want ones
they're in the middle and I think you
could use callgraph information to help
definitely we haven't gone that step yet
but definitely we could totally any any
information you've got we could put into
it and further increase the accuracy
I've just been focused on okay how far
can we push the words themselves and
then once once we get there and figure
out what that barrier is keep going did
I see another yeah have you thought
about presenting the search results in a
more graphical structural way like maybe
as you build up this model of all these
functions you have this sort of
functional model of the whole app and it
might be interesting to view the search
results in the Contex like graph or a
call graph or definitely so actually I
personally really like seeing results oh
I really like seeing results in a call
graph for format and that's part of the
reason why we've worked towards
integrating search and exploration
because that allows us to present it in
a more graphical way and you just get
more of a context oh that's my personal
feeling I don't know what developers in
general want to see and that we'd have
to undertake a study to see what how do
people want to see it and in an informal
study of a handful of developers we
found that depending on what they were
using it for they really wanted a map
where they could zoom in and out um so
presenting the results in a format where
they could kind of zoom out and get more
context or zoom in which I think you
guys have done work
on but I we haven't actually gone that
far yet we're working on can we
automatically restrict that graph so
we're not overwhelming them with
information using these search and
exploration tools but definitely how
that how these results are presented so
far all we've really contributed there
is querer reformulation and that phrase
hierarchy but that's definitely not
where we want it to stay we want to keep
evolving it but we need to study what
developers really want to see first
unless we can Leverage What some other
people have
studied other questions on this
okay I CU I can show you some results of
what we've
done
okay all right so we evaluated our Swan
Bay search technique with some existing
search techniques so there's elex which
is eclipse's regular expression based
search it's similar to grep we also use
Google Desktop search which has been
integrated into Eclipse that's called
GES and then we also have fine concept
which is really where we started from
that was the inspiration for our
approach and it's similar to the verb o
approach that we used before except that
it also uses synonyms in the query re
formulation so find concept given a verb
direct object query it searches for verb
Doo pairs in comments and Method
signatures and allows the user to do
query reformulation with synonyms and
co-occurring verbs and direct objects
and swam T has a similar interface to
Google Desktop search because we're
using this similar query mechanism and
the relevance is determined by our swam
score exceeding some threshold which we
dynamic ically determined based on the
average of the top 20
results and we used for search tasks we
used eight concerns from a previous
study which had 60 relevant methods we
were searching for across 10,000
irrelevant ones in four different
programs and in terms of queries we used
the top performing queries based on a
prior evaluation we didn't want to
compare how well users could use these
search tools we wanted to see when a
user was really able to get a good query
in terms of precision recall our F
measure
when were they most effective and
compare the techniques under those ideal
situations so the measures we used again
were Precision recall and the fmeasure
commonly used in information
retrieval so what does it look like so
here we have a box plot of the fmeasure
just as a quick reminder the Shaded
middle region is the middle 50% of the
data horizontal line in the middle is
median plus is the mean and we can see
as we look from elex to GES fine concept
and swam te all the way to the right if
we look at the height of the box of
swamp te we we consider swam te to be
more consistently effective than the
other techniques it doesn't have the
shortest box but on the whole it has the
the smallest box that's also
highest when we analyzed recall and
precision we found that elex similar to
grep had good recall but the Precision
was so poor that overall it it inundated
the developer with results that
Irrelevant in terms of precision we
found that swam te and fine concept were
best so that means using phrasal
Concepts did improve our Precision but
in terms of recall GES which was the
Google equivalent and swam T were the
best so the advantage of swam over our
prior competitor find concept was that
it had just as good Precision but it
slightly improve the recall because it's
using a more General representation of
phrasal Concepts and not just verb
direct objects anymore
and so this was really more a
preliminary study and we' like to do a
more widespread study to help flesh out
these results because these results are
not statistically significant because
we're using a small number of queries
because we're just using the best in
terms of precision recall and F measure
and so we want to do a more General
broader study to further evaluate this
so slightly Switching gears just for a
second yes maybe I should but do you
have an example of what kind of qu
queries users are issuing in these uh
each so each type of SE
is going to give a different type of
query so elex is going to be regular
expression query type in a regular
expression they're going to doar print
or something like that and the users
were allowed to interact with the tool
until they were satisfied and stop give
them like here's what you're searching
for now implement it using that and
thanks okay good question thank you yep
so yeah and each of them GES and swm T
were the same keyword queries find
concept had a specific verb followed by
a specific direct object and they could
look at the search results and stop when
they were satisfied and that the last
query was the one we used and the sort
of things they were searching for were
like finding a method that prints out
logging information or something well it
was slightly more it was more feature
oriented so they might be shown a
screenshot and said find the code that
implements this feature they might be
given a snippet of documentation and
said okay find the code that implements
this aspect of the system so they're
more feature-based
okay
sorry good question so I'm slightly
Switching gears because after we've done
this General search to find these seeds
to start from then we want also further
refine that and explore the program
further so but these are really two
different problems with two different
goals so in search we're trying to find
seeds whereas in Exploration we're
starting from these seed starting points
we've got these pegs in the code we can
start hanging on we're trying to build
our understanding of the code around it
locally that and we're looking at
relevant elements that are structurally
connected to these seed starting points
so in search our goal is really high
Precision because we're searching the
entire code base so we have this huge
set of methods we're trying to prune
down whereas an exploration we're trying
to improve the recall
further so our solution was to use
phrasal Concepts and swam to improve
precision and actually even though I've
complained about the bag of words
approach for information retrieval it's
actually very good for high recall it's
very greedy so when we're exploring we
actually are using bag of words and our
solution we created a tool called door
the program Explorer it used program
structure and natural language as well
as location signature versus
body um let's see so in general this is
like the example I showed before we use
the frequency of the query words so for
example I have do add on the left and an
irrelevant method delete Comon on the
right and the relevant method had six
occurrences the query words the
irrelevant one just had two and we
waited the contribution of the frequency
based on the signature was being more
relevant than the body so we train two
weights using logistic regression on a
training sample to calculate that
score so and we also compared it to
additional techniques so we compared our
Dora score which was more advanced to
two naive approaches and an or and
returned true if all the query words
were present or returned true that
something was relevant if any one of the
query words were relevant and we also
compared our technique to a purely
structural approach called Suede and
evaluated on eight concerns M by three
independent developers which translated
to 160 methods and over 1,800 edges with
overlap and what we
found was that using natural language
and program structure together does
outperform just using program structure
but you have to be careful how you
integrate that natural language
information just putting natural
language information for example if you
selected the and naive approach you
would be worse off than just using
program structure alone so how you
combine the natural language and
information is very important so success
is highly dependent on the textual
scoring performance and our more
advanced Dora did appear to outperform
the other
techniques so our real question is
though is if we take our search our
highly precise search technique and a
greedier exploration technique like Dora
to improve recall how much more of the
concern can we get how much more many
more relevant results can we get for
each search task so we did
is we compared the three
state-of-the-art search techniques with
swam search plus Dora exploration so in
the bottom we have elex which is like
grap GES and fine concept and then at
the all the way to the right we have
swam search plus door exploring one Edge
away and if we look at the medians we
can actually see that the median results
are significantly higher than for search
alone so right now we've seen that this
is a promising direction to go in that
we can continue improving the results in
general if you're going to pick one
solution you're going to want to pick
the solution that has the highest median
that's most effective most of the time
we're never going to have one silver
bullet that solves that's a perfect
search all the time but search plus Dora
does a better job in general than the
other
techniques and we also found that
results would be further improved if we
assumed there was a human pruning away
irrelevant search results before they
went to the exploration phase so in the
first bar S Plus Dora I took every
search result in the top 10 and explored
one Edge away and that was the accuracy
if we assume a human is pruning away
some of those irrelevant ones we get
even better results but again the F
measure is still only at 60 because
that's about the limit that words are
going to get us even with the program
structure even with
Dora so this is a preliminary result and
we found it was very exciting we also
did some other studies and found that
when we were searching using any base
search technique if we went two to three
three edges away from the starting seeds
we could get like 100% of the relevant
results so within two to three edges of
the call graph you can get almost an
entire concern because programs are so
highly interconnected I believe is the
reason for that so did you look at how
many edges that required looking
at um well it grew I mean if you can
reach like 20% or 30% of the program
from any point in three edges then yeah
no The Sweet Spot was like returning the
top seven results and then
going and looking at the top five
results two edges away we found that was
The Sweet Spot it was for so we got 80%
of the correct results across the eight
concerns we were looking at using that
so there is so it's possible that you
can pick these thresholds and combine
them in such a way that you can get a
win because we found that to get every
relevant result we needed to add two
more results so it grew exponentially
but there was a threshold where you're
not overwhelming the developer and
you're still returning more relevant
results but finding that and it might be
different from person to person as well
because different people want to look at
different numbers of results different
programs right exactly well and it's
highly dependent on the program
itself yeah and actually what makes this
problem so challenging is that the query
is really one of the most important
determining factors in the success of
the search even more so than like word
choice in the program and the structure
because if the query is a bad query
doesn't matter how good the search Tech
technique is it's going to be a bad
result so it it's a function of the
query itself the word distribution in
the program and the structure so that's
why it's so hard to make a general
solution so what's the research impact
we've had so far going this work with
navigation exploration tools they were
typically manual and slow for large and
Scattered code we've added automated
support to leverage using natural
language and program structure
information as well as location to
outperform competing state-of-the-art
techniques in terms of search tools they
typically return irrelevant results and
Mis relevant ones we've helped improve
the Precision by capturing the semantics
of word occurrences using these phrasal
Concepts in swam as well as improving
recall by combining search and
exploration but there's certainly more
we could do along these
lines and so just to summarize so the
insights I've tried to share with you
today are combining natural language and
program structure taking advantage of
word location and using word context
through phrasal Concepts and so I've
talked about using that to improve
creater formulation software search and
program
exploration but there's tons of other
software engineering applications where
this could be used I am just one woman
and I haven't had time to try it try it
out in all these different places so
swam captures phrasal Concepts and our
goal is that this can become an
interface for software engineering tool
designers and researchers to help
improve linguistic analyses for software
that's our long-term goal in trying to
develop
this and in future we're hoping to
really explore other ways that text and
specifically this swam model can be used
for other software engineering
applications to solve other software
engineering problems and to study to
keep pushing this search further study
what actual developers are searching for
so we can further refine and better meet
developer needs maybe they're not all
just general purpose and we need to
start
specializing okay so that's it for me
unless you have more
questions yes well thank you for
that have one more question uh have you
thought at all about how one might
change languages or uh annotations that
programmers can add to improve this
process I I'm really more interested in
the language like is there anything we
can do with the language level to make
this easier and more accurate well I
think if the right now I uh developers
have tons of choice in choosing their
identifiers and I think that's great
power because we can be really flexible
but at the same time it makes it really
hard there's no standard naming
conventions if in how you're calling
methods and naming the methods if it's
slightly more forced in the structure of
verbs and direct objects there' be a lot
less ambiguity if I knew like okay this
is the action that's taking place and
this is the objects it's working on I
that would make a lot clearer I think
for what we're trying to do so
clarifying the noun verb right the
action and the objects yeah and and
really what we found in general is
actions and verbs in source code are
typically used very interchangeably and
synonymously and that's actually the
biggest source of of issue um but the
nouns they tend to be pretty consistent
because they're typically objects which
get one name and they're used everywhere
that's one fixed name so it's an
interesting blend of of word choice and
word restriction it's way more
restrictive than a random average
natural language document because you
don't get all these different forms of
the words because once the identifier is
fixed everywhere else in the program has
to use it that same exact way but then
the actions those typically aren't
objects typically don't encapsulate
actions so there's a lot more word
choice and variability so anything from
execute to fire to do we have so many
synonyms for that one simple concept
compute compare I mean yeah there's a
lot of different verbs that are used to
mean the same thing so it seems like it
may not be actually changing the
language but helping them as developing
so like you could have an IDE MH that
either gives you like choices about the
vers you should be using at certain
points or like does like the word
squiggles underneath right like yeah are
you sure you mean
this yeah like we had a method like do
print or you know what are the semantics
of of helping verbs like can fire like
can something fire what does that mean
for what that method is doing and
there's a lot you can you can program in
and learn from how it's used in it right
now like for example host at all they
did a Java programmer phrasebook where
they analyze the verbs and when is a
verb used and what does that method
structure typically look like when that
verb is used there and so they could
debug uh poorly named methods and so
encoding that and building it into the
IDE would really help us better leverage
the text that's in there because it'd be
more organized the the more ambiguity
you can take away the better the results
are going to
be MH sort of in the opposite direction
though like you could try to preserve
that ambiguity as much as possible in
your syntactic analysis right so that
you don't just take I I mean I don't
know to what extent you do this already
are you taking sort of a one best
analysis or do you have some packed
Forest representation of the natural
language side or um we do we try and
preserve the original as much as
possible um I mean of course it explodes
right right but in practice so a lot of
my work is in machine translation right
and so when you throw syntax in you
can't explore all the syntactic
possibilities presented by one English
sentence when you're translating into
Japanese but but you can explore a
highly likely subset and if you have an
ambiguity preserving representation that
packs away some of the exponential
combinations we can get much better wins
that way than just by looking over the
one best at synthtic so right now in in
the model I've shown you it's it's just
one best I I pick one way of doing it
but we have we had an undergrad that was
working on using more advanced analysis
and using more even more positional
information um and she was is looking at
all the different possibilities and then
choosing between them using accuracies
things like that um and so we have
pushed it it's not quite
integrated because every time you change
the part of speech tagging you have to
change the parsing rule implementation
and so we're working on making a very
general way that you could read that
into a file or something to make it
really easy to change but right now our
challenge is how do we design this
interface in the system so that to make
that really easy to change in the future
so but definitely and we the more you
can take it we've we we've tried to
avoid presenting multiple possibilities
other than something like an equivalence
like okay these two things are connected
we think they're the same we've tried to
avoid giving two parses because they
could have completely different semantic
parses if you have two different
syntactic parses so we've tried to to to
pick one but maybe affiliate accuracy
with it that's not implemented yet but
our goal would be with each rules
associated in accuracy for both the part
of speech tagging and the semantic
parsing all right
cool great
thanks all
right